good evening everyone and we're on we
are on Olli I think we just had the 30
minute countdown we're definitely on and
good evening everyone and welcome to the
first ever live podcast webinar this is
definitely new to me so bear with
however I've got some great panelists
with me this evening in Olli Rhonda and
Andrew who are going to do a very short
intro very soon and but just quickly
just to set the scene and to help all of
you guides and firstly what's going to
be really important on this and I want
to make sure that all of you guys you'll
give me your time which I really
appreciate I want you to get the most
out of it so you should be able to see
and the Q&A section on the right and
basically at any point that you want to
ask a question get involved then you can
just type it there and when that
questions there you're going to be able
to click up vote and answer the question
so feel free to do that at any point and
up vote the questions that you
definitely get ask because I want to
make sure that you get your questions
answered and so before we go into the
intro all of you should know that this
podcast is sponsor supported by hunted
and and I think we're just talking about
this and a minute ago but I think in the
the current adversity and challenges
there's definitely been a huge number of
recruiters unfortunately being made with
London and have now got overcome new
challenge of potentially getting a new
job and speaking to Hunter today they've
sort of worked really hard to ensure
that they're showcasing the brands that
are definitely recruiting and are
planning on growing so make sure that
you check those guys out and if you are
in an unfortunate position and then
check that out so look let's get started
with run day for you if you go first
just for everyone's benefit and
introduce yourself everyone and then
we'll go from there
brilliant thanks very much kitchen and
welcome everybody
it's absolutely great to be doing this
live
Rhonda D'Ambrosio I am the
transformation director that even able
an organization that supports
recruitment businesses for L&D based on
a foundation of good mindset
I'm also founder of mental health in
recruitment and initiative that's going
to be getting driven out more across
2020 and that's me a pioneer for good
mindset and mental health in the
recruitment industry Thank You Rhonda he
was gonna ask oh no fighting
hi guys yeah it's Oliver Perry here I so
I am nearly six years into equipment I'm
still very much in the trenches I that's
role was five years back in the UK and I
took the the jump to move to Dublin so
I'm in I've been in Dublin for that six
months now I lead a team of four
building manager very much yeah very
much foot soldier still in the game like
and literally you've got the question
already so let's answer it where did
Ollie get a shed from so let's make that
really clear why why are you in a shed
this - this was this was gone we can he
know my girlfriend's got me yeah yeah we
got yeah yeah yeah this is this is this
is mana my girlfriend's like negotiation
in terms of what she wanted in the house
and what I wanted in the house and the
only one thing I wanted was a man said
of the absolutely no reason whatsoever I
was six months ago I made the decision
maybe I knew coronavirus has come in and
I'd need somewhere to do some work that
was the first question straight out the
gate thank you we'll grashof for that
I'm not surprised that what was asked
that question but and just for everyone
I'm sure a lot of people seen you on
LinkedIn but short intro to you Andrea
and then gonna ask you guys some
questions yeah sure thanks for having me
on thanks are hunted for organizing as
well it's good to be here
so I'm answering McCaskill 15-years
recruitment in xx search and at the
moment I split myself between kind of
both sides of the hiring equation so I
spend half my time working with
executives who are on the move and I've
got a business called career jump which
helps them with that transition and the
other half working with disruptive
recruitment leaders on strategy
marketing social selling and scale ups
so yeah really pleased to be here cool
thank you and solar as the original
theme for the event that we was going to
do in person was caught vein resilience
and going the distance in recruitment
I think we've obviously the the
challenges over there the last couple
days and weeks I think it can be more
topical I think we'll definitely touch
on the coronavirus but this this live
pull off a B'nai is not going to be all
about the coronavirus because I think
we're just hit with it every single
second I think there's lows to talk
about in terms of resilience in
recruitment so I guess firstly let's
start with what what do you what does
resilience in recruitment mean to you
guys and let's start there when I say
the word resilience in recruitment what
does it mean to you I think for me in
recruit in recruitment and with most
things resilience is quality of thinking
it's how flexibly we think about things
and how well we can respond and adapt to
the challenges around us like that Ali
yeah so I am for me it's the if the
difference between hope and certainty so
the net margin between those two things
so how hopeful you are of things
happening or how certain you are of
things happening in the wider those two
things become apart and the more
resilient you at you evidently have to
be so it's just for me it's it's that
gap in between those two things narrow
that gap and you produce the amount of
time you have to be resilient basically
like that really interesting little
equation haven't heard that before
I was great yeah what does it mean to
you sir I think the salient C's
mastering your emotions in your ego at
times when they're tested mmm like that
and I think recruitment and ego
definitely yeah I think that sometimes a
lot of people think they do they just
come both together then they that so
look love that let's go let's go
straight into this I'd love to just get
some stories out of you guys and what
what has been sort of your lowest point
in your recruitment career so far and
how did he bounced back and keep going I
don't wanna always go first
god there's been so many I've been in
the industry for 22 nearly 23 years so I
think for me personally the biggest one
was around about 2008 with the downturn
across various markets I was a year into
starting up my own recruitment business
my the technologies and you know people
didn't want to spend money and I think
the hardest part is everywhere you
looked and Linkedin wasn't quite as big
then it was at this sort of the dawn of
everybody using LinkedIn sir certainly
not the level of videos and presents
that we've got today but yeah what I
found is that people were talking us
into a recession
you know the negativity the oh it's doom
oh it's awful and we knew so many people
around us that had also set up at a
similar time that just decided no we
needed the stability so and you know the
way in which we responded to it back
then you know we would set up
if anyone's listened to the podcast and
for those that haven't know I set up
because I wanted flexible working my I
was a mama had two very small children I
the industry wasn't giving me the
flexibility to do the job for you know a
business a company so I did it for
myself and we had to really dig deep it
with the relationship building and and
and that for me is I'm not going to say
it's how we got through it
but by being authentic and building real
relationships with people as opposed to
just those transactional placements to
get money on the board or to get a deal
sort of I think save might be a bit too
you know dramatic but it enabled us to
keep doing what we were doing and we had
a very very clear reason for needing to
keep moving forward
I think I'm not that's definitely gonna
be important in in the president from
from from that experience for sure and
only what what's been that's what's been
the solve lowest point for you out of
interests as you said you're with
someone that's in the trenches you're a
foot soldier what what what's been the
lowest point for you and how did you
balance back and get through that yeah
so I am - mines quite simple in terms of
it was kind of like an 18 months
recruitment wall that I hit in my first
job it was hard it's hard to quantify at
the time but it's more like do I want to
do this is it right for me in your way
kind of thing and I can't really give
myself any credit for getting out of it
a lot of it was it was the people around
me was the management at the time my
colleagues at the time and it was a bit
of a reset thanks to their kind of
positive in it wasn't if it wasn't for
if I was hand in my notice into a
different manager or a different
colleague or whatever it might be a
different outcome but I am but yeah I
was very lucky for the people around me
at that time that helped me through what
was all the things that they communicate
there and a lot of it a lot of it was a
lot of it was talking about actually
what had happened so I think you create
this theory in your head that's actually
not true of your lack of ability or your
lack of confidence and it's actually
sometimes it takes somebody else how you
what's happened before you can actually
see what's happened yourself and so a
lot of it was that and obviously there's
a lot of a lot of belief and a lot of a
lot of like positivity internally you
can do this it nothing nothing kind of
wizardry but sometimes just a bit of a
bit of a pat on the back and a bit of
but a positivity goes a long way so yeah
and ever since then in it to be fair
I've had quite a nice upwards curve and
stuff at the moment new market new desks
more teams start of nature so there's
daily challenges but yeah that's
probably that 18 months period of being
in recruitment was probably at my lowest
yeah okay thanks for sharing Andrew I
think whenever people see you it's just
a big old smile so oh no and so yeah
what yet Sheriff I'd love to hear sort
of a tough time for you and yeah there's
tapes mate your podcast is the most
aptly named podcast on the planet yeah
the roller coasters absolutely right so
definitely the lowest point I'm not
going to go into detail because I'd
rather not stop in front of 150 but
definitely the the worst one I had was
the day before last year's kickoff
meeting when I was running an executive
search business with people I cared
about my wife as the FT blah blah blah I
got it was the yeah my wife is EFT yeah
so we were all really into tangled lot
and my best friend's to work in there I
got a text message from the other
shareholders to go to a hotel and
everybody got wiped out Wow
so that was devastating absolutely
devastating on a but you know it's a
cruel game sometimes like eight what you
know now is what those kind of
once-in-a-lifetime scenarios but I
remember a load of time so recruitment
just screws with you like yeah I
remember you know missing out on
promotion targets by a couple of grand
or having a having a drop out which
meant the commission that I thought it
had coming that was gonna be a holiday
in two months time it disappears you
know like because you've already spent
it in your mind right yeah and equipment
just has this horrible way of kicking
you in the nuts when you don't see it
coming and and it can be really really
de freitas oh yeah yeah a roller coaster
as you so aptly put it now thank you so
and before I ask next question I'm Kevin
Adam shared a great question that quite
a few
people have voted on so let's go into
that because this was sort of the next
sort of thing that I wouldn't start
talking to you guys about obviously all
of you have been involved in recruiting
for your own teams and works alongside
other people but Kevin Adam asked do you
think resilience is an inherent skill or
trait or is it something that you can
train what do we think about that you
can train it okay
yeah elaborate talk to us well it's
something that compounds over time it
calluses over time so I know for a fact
and and this is the funny thing about
resilience and the pain of what you have
to go through and you're showing
resilience is actually its growth isn't
it you mean you're building growth while
you're going through those challenges so
I've definitely taught myself albeit I
have noticed I've been eating too many
cookies and reaching for a beer every
night this week so you know it does
still sit underneath you have to be very
very self aware and work at it all the
time but the more you can learn to you
know practice things like mindfulness
and manage your stay and detach your
emotions internally from what's
happening externally and focus on the
controllables you can you can build up
that strength over time here in my
opinion yeah what would you Ollie and
Rhonda what would you think about that
yeah absolutely
I think I think resilience is a lot
about your environment in general so the
people around you specifically or
management have such a such a big
influence on on your ability to be
resilient after the fact or before the
fact more importantly like Andy says in
terms of the growth to get there so yeah
absolutely of course and of course with
everything there's a there's a lot that
any individual needs to do but yeah
absolutely the people around you your
management have a big big say in in how
an individual is going to be resilient
in recruitment okay
I would say that you know if you look at
how we're programmed very early on from
birth and in schools and the experiences
that we have in life some of us have
great experiences and we naturally have
a quality of thinking
a positive way to view the world we are
solutions orientated those of you that
are familiar with Carol Dweck's work may
say that yes those individuals are in a
growth mindset you know that is in to a
degree that's an inherent in built thing
that has almost been cultivated over
time and where it starts to get sort of
interesting is the individuals that
haven't been able to maybe cope with the
things that have happened to them
haven't been great quality of thinkers
and these are the people like Andrew
said that absolutely you can work with
you can talk to them about the way in
which they process things the way in
which they acknowledge what's happened
to them what they're looking at in terms
of what is in their control what they
can influence versus the things that
they can't deal with their influence but
kind of like and Claire Mohammed she
just popped up and asked a question
about resilience being a scar or growing
pains
you know resilience is a almost
sometimes use a rubber band you know you
get a fresh rubber band out the packet
and you know that's gonna stretch but
sometimes more you stretch it little by
little the further it'll go you couldn't
necessarily give it to that point
straightaway but over a period of time
of sort of seeing where your boundaries
are and seeing where your not your break
points but your perceptible areas are
you know that's the continual work in
progress that's the acknowledgement of
the things that have happened and you
know do you mind me jumping in and
referencing John's question about the
interview process is this it really
pulls together because you know
invariably when people have dealt with
things that whether it's adverse and
adversity whether it challenging things
in our personal lives when we overcome
those and when we get through them our
mind knows that we've done it before so
therefore we can do again and that
builds an inner confidence and a sort of
a focus that all ties together yeah
there's a really cool way of spotting
resilience that interview that I believe
yeah so Andrew the the question was from
John just for is it how do you recommend
questioning for resilience as part of
the interview process
yeah no great question the answer is the
questions don't matter as much as the
answers that are coming back what I mean
by that is somebody who's resilient will
own their journey
hmm so they'll have an internal locus of
control so if you were to say to a
candidate who I would say would be low
on resilience taught me through your CV
they'll say when I went to the first
company in the product was rubbish then
England so I had to win anything well
yeah always externalized yeah if you if
you look at people who owned their
journey and they say when I went to the
first company and I didn't do the due
diligence around the product and so it
turned out for market but they have this
they're not passengers in their own life
they have this ownership and internal
locus of control and that's an absolute
I'll tell you if you're interviewing for
your team tomorrow I would take internal
locus of control over pretty much
anything it's it's yeah absolutely the
one yeah that's awesome so I guess so we
definitely agree then the and resilience
is something that yeah it isn't it isn't
inherent it's something that you can
continue to work at it's free run
experience these sorts of things so I
guess on this sort of tangent then how
can people because a lot of our job
particularly maybe obviously yours job
now Ally and you've spoken about the
managers and environment and obviously
likewise if you run the but how can
people that do have people around them
that they're responsible for how can
they start instilling resilience in them
and the people around them how can they
go about that and approach that so from
a from a very sorry from a very like
low-level point of view right so we're
talking about a consult and doing their
day job and one of the biggest things
for me is is to de-risk a lot of a lot
of what you're doing so have your
processes and be honest with yourself in
terms of with yourself but also your
management have an influence indeed risk
in what you're doing a lot of a lot of
resilience comes from doing things wrong
for such a period of time and then
getting smack bang with with there's
something out of the blue then all of a
sudden oh my god I have to be resilient
now because it's all gone wrong so from
a low-level point of view managing a
trainee or a rookie or a senior
has to be it's a it's about it's about
understanding what you're doing every
single point of that process and
de-risking every single point of that
process to understand what what's going
to happen it's also when you say do your
risking you're saying just let me know
Willie you will get rejected when we're
doing this business development session
the number of times yeah you may not
communicate what the other the
challenges are they're gonna face yeah
absolutely honest honesty is so
important and but it has to have a for
me it has to have a real level of
positivity in support I think you see so
many times in recruitment people hitting
other consultants with the stick to try
and prepare them for getting hit with
the stick from a clown a candidate it
baffles me a little bit because then you
kind of say anyway you're gonna have to
be resilient double over now because I'm
gonna be as hard as I say I'm against
that kind of thing I'm on about like I'm
on about the being honest with them
about what's happening but making sure
it has it making sure as levels of
positivity otherwise if they're worried
about and rejected by the client and
then getting hit by sticking by oh yeah
I'ma be double yeah yeah I would coin
what Ollie saying when you talk to us
the way the language I often use is
about clear expectations if you set
clear expectations with people the
people around you and you tell them what
to expect so somebody brand-new come
into our industry that is told to pick
up the phone it's told to make the calls
you know what we all know that it's I'm
not saying it's impossible but it's very
very rare that you're going to make five
calls and have success on every five of
those calls so if you make people aware
about whether it's called whether it's
about process whether it's about you
know other people and how the team works
and how you're expected to behave not
only does that build trust but it
definitely works towards building
resilience mmm I like that and then I
guess on this then I think like how how
do you guys think the sort of importance
or needs for resilience has changed as
the industry's evolved I mean
particularly
you wonder you've been in the market
longer than me nollie and so as you as
you say around of your story the Lynx
and wasn't very prevalent there than
these things but like like how do you
think
yeah the need or the importance of
resilience has changed as the industry's
evolved and if you don't mind jumping in
you know I think that um it's evolved in
a couple of ways some real largely
positive and others in somewhat negative
way if you look at the different
demographics we have and the different
generations that are coming into the
workplace the newer generations you
Jen's Ed's and and so on they are living
in a world with a very very different
set of rules you know back in back in
the days when Andrew and I were you know
dinosaur on it about you know we didn't
have we didn't have take we didn't have
email you know we were lucky if we had
God had to actually don't know how old
you are and you I might be doing you a
massive disservice
I had a fax and we used to stand at the
facts and send CV through and stuff like
that and an old mentor yes so you know I
think that somewhat working in those
times and conditions you you know that
builds a level of resilience because we
didn't get the sort of instant
gratification that a lot of recruiters
now get basically the connectivity and
the tech and everything else so what me
by Matt with regards to you know you
Jen's Ed's and that the workforce that's
going to come into play you know they
have been switched on since birth you
know my kids are so technical you know
they use on all the platforms they're
using tick tock so that also means that
they're more susceptible to some of the
bad stuff that happens online
you know the trolling and everything
else so on some levels I think that they
are going to have a level of resilience
but also you know that mindset that
mental health it's becoming far more of
a you know a normality you know I don't
believe we're there yet as an industry
you know I'm how I feel about that but
you know yeah yeah not
Ricardo I'm not saying and it's about
entitlement what I'm saying is this is
just the way the world now we have to
adapt yeah and yeah if we don't adapt
how we gonna overcome yeah I think and I
think roses just asked a question which
is really in line with that I'd love to
get your thoughts on that which was yeah
do you feel people have become shielded
from needing to be resilient with the
emergence of technology in social media
etc eg the lack of cold-calling yeah
exactly nothing that that's interesting
right so I think yeah I think you're
right it's the odd don't to put this out
in cases don't get any likes and being
resilient around that and all the
different things now rather than being
willing to pick up the phone and getting
told no number of times and and if it's
out the Matt Andrew what do you think
from your experience in your own journey
yeah I think how we get resilience out
of our teams has changed mine when I
started it was very much about just
beating people effectively yeah you know
emotionally beating people into everyone
kind of took an Army Navy SEAL hell weak
type approach to it where where it was
kind of sink or swim you're throwing at
the deep end all that and that's that
that's you know that's questionable how
relevant that is now and I think a lot
of organizations need to ship so how'd
you build resilience now well my view
and a lot of work that I'm doing with
recruitment organizations working with
one called colapse at the moment we've
done a lot of work on this is around
purpose so I think how you build
resilience in teams now is true being
able to define a mission and a purpose
that underpinned your organization
because the the generation coming
through now are very purpose-driven they
don't have necessarily the financial
pain to the level that we did when we
started and aren't purely money
motivated albeit they are of course
money motivates to an extent and so you
have to be able to articulate something
that's bigger than the organization that
then makes those people resilient to
delivering on that mission
because it's in service of something
that's bigger than just hitting their
numbers and those I'm really predicting
in terms of all the uncertainty in the
market and everything at the moment that
the businesses that go well during this
period will be the ones that have a
clearly defined purpose a mission that
underpins what they do because that's
what people will fight for and serve and
push through for yeah I think such a
thing that nothing you put that really
well and I think that that Mike Richards
just put a question around that and you
should feel free to elaborate it
slightly but Mike Richard just said
going the distance as Andrew said
internal resilience is great but we are
recruiting an uncertain external world
currently what would advice would you
give recruiting these weird times to
prepare for the recovery so is it very
much then like really be clear and
understand why you're doing what you're
doing and what you're in it for and and
why you're serving the people you want
to is that is that part of it then
that's gonna help people get through
this and prepare for the recovery yeah
and I think we're seeing that anyway
people are serving their communities in
a really positive way I I did a live
broadcast this morning when I had some
time and the first thing I did was
compliment the recruitment industry
because I think we get a terrible rap
and yet this week I've seen it's been
amazing the response yeah in terms of
like economy there's so many people
doing stuff for free
heaps people working for free or in
career coaching for free raptorex free
all sorts right now I think that's great
to see
yeah so I've been really impressed I
think there's yes
to prepare for what's to come we need
the mission element that's that's for
sure but we also need to be agile with
our services we've got to stay relevant
we need to be thinking about you know
things such as flexible resourcing
models whereby we can deliver in trims
not on a day rate for six months but
unbundled and by the hour and I trade
them into the marketplace we need to be
looking at putting teams in we need to
be looking at helping identify the big
pain points of where we're at and how us
as an organization and our people can
solve it all that stuff I think need to
be super agile but super agile in
service of a mission and a purpose
bigger than an individual run then if
it's out to that because obviously I
think you definitely obviously from the
adverse to um pretty definite add to
innovate and and and yeah be adapt be
agile anything to adds to that from your
sort of experience on that point I just
think tying in Andrew said about the
company mission the purpose but also to
the individual mission and purpose and
making sure those two things are aligned
so a huge amount of the work that I'll
do will always sort of start with quite
a lot of stuff around deep behavioral
motivators and drivers to make sure that
everybody is facing in the right
direction so you know if you've got an
organization that's facing what we're
facing you know yes it's very tempting
to sit behind closed doors and think
about a strategy and you know have a
creative conversation at a senior level
but open it out to the workforce and
include inning and crater at creating
that environment of trust to find a
creative approach to what people could
be doing and giving everybody a voice
I think individually you've got that
level of empowerment then when people
feel that they are a part of something
and that we are all in this together and
it just it it does breed creativity it
creates a safe space for people to you
know put an idea out there do something
different and reach out to clients I
love this bit around the transparency in
the open communication as well Rondo in
terms of that trust building I think too
often we're not candid enough with the
people that are in the mission with us
and yeah I think people you know what
they invent in their heads is a lot
worse than the reality quite quite often
and and if it's not then they need to
know too and so I think I've never ever
met a recruitment consultant in my life
who moaned that their director over
communicated with them yeah it's never
happened Nadia so I think I think yeah
that comms piece that Trust building
piece that all helps create
psychological safety and one to be the
expert on that but it brings it creates
psychological safety doesn't it so then
people can then continue to be resilient
and push through
yeah and then on surrogate gone ELISA
what I was gonna say on my question
about what to what to do now basically
in turn yeah I find it really
interesting because as a recruiter now
in in terms of this week of speaking to
candidates and clients you've kind of
misses in the solution so I haven't got
an answer but you've kind of made your
bed at this point in terms of how you've
treated your clients and candidates up
until this point right and and you and
you were like you were lay in that bed
for a little while to come so like in
terms of cold calling a new business now
and asking them for a hand you're on the
back foot and it's it's really the the
recruiters now who have treated their
clients and candidates properly up until
this point and are gonna be the ones
that they get through this and I know
that's I know that's not not a solution
but I love that and it's also not just
the courts of Canada it's just to add to
that it's the employees right yeah
I think as you're saying we all need to
make sure we're on the right side of
history on this thing when the dust
settles and the companies that stick by
their employees who are only shedding
people because it's for survival but
it's a last resort but the companies
that are finding ways to put their
people first serve their clients and
their candidates they can have a huge
competitive advantage when this thing
springs back and rightly so because
they're going about it the right way and
I think what what I just wanted to I
wanted to talk about Joanna's question
when we're talking about the sort of
individual mission and purpose and these
types of things I think what I
definitely had to learn the hard way and
get better at earlier and the my
recruitment career was definitely taking
the emotion out of things and so I think
it's just ties in quite nice with the
individual piece so Joanna's question
consultants build really strong
long-term relationships with their
candidates clients how do you train
consultants to keep a certain level of
emotional detachment to ensure that when
they are let down it's not taking person
rather than professionally but I
definitely had to learn that the hard
way what are the thoughts on man great
question I I think it's a fantastic
question and what I would say is it's
not in my experience not necessarily
about emotional detachment because
you're right these relationships become
quite meaningful it's about setting from
the outset very clear boundaries and
understanding what that relation looks
like relationship looks like and you
know I had it the other day it was
somebody that I'm talking to we were
talking about some commercials as two
individuals we get on brilliantly and
instead of saying you know Rhonda and
this person like Rhonda and him it's
like well actually what's going on with
you know even Abel and you know Hisham
actually Hisham which our company calls
yeah you know so it's it's separating
and creating those boundaries to be able
to have these conversations here at this
level and then having a commercial
conversation where there's an impact and
you can talk organizational level and
you know I'm talking about doing that
from when I was running my own business
so you know if you're working for
somebody else it's much easier to do
that I think if you detach yourself too
much are you gonna be authentic you know
or is that going to be picked up on I
don't know what you guys think only what
do you think on that how have you got
there right sort of taken the emotion
out of things and not taking things so
personally
all right yeah I yeah I got the question
I didn't know you asked
I actually think emotional attachment is
probably almost a strength in a
recruiter being able to I know I agree
that too much of it can can make you
fall off a cliff when something happens
but I definitely I definitely take
somebody who's got a lot of emotional
attachment in what they're doing over
somebody who has no emotional attachment
I think just just genuinely the the
service you will offer will be better so
I agree may get to a point where you
might have to step in but talking from
my experience
I'd say the more emotional attachment to
what you're doing the better hmm okay
and really like James's question on do
you believe that people who have faced
adversity or hardship prior to getting
into recruitment are predisposed to
being more resilient than the job in the
job sorry what do we think about that
it's funny going on yeah yeah no I think
I think you all have preconceptions when
you interview people like this
unconscious bias that you do and I I
developed something that I'm not saying
is right at all but you kind of can't
get away with it but speaking to people
who have had really bad jobs before and
seeing them as somebody who may step in
to recruitment and and see the best of
it and it's funny they you speak to some
people who had jobs that they hated and
they were work in all God's hours and
they were doing a really mundane job and
then stepping into recruitment and
looking at it and being like what do you
mean you have to be resilient so funny
really I actually I actually do I
actually do agree that to a certain
degree that you can having a job was had
show resilience prior to getting into
recruitment definitely odd link it back
to what what was said about personal
experiences and adversity and hardship
outside of the employment world you know
Hisham you know I talked about my
experience with my mum my mum being ill
asked getting told that she had the
terminal illness and losing her very
very quickly and when you go through
this level of adversity it gives you
perspective and perspective is a massive
leveler because it enables you to take a
step back and understand what's really
really important and what isn't so you
know if I have if I have a really bad
call if you know I'm shut down if I
don't get an outcome that I want to
something for me it's never gonna be as
bad as some of the stuff I've had to
deal with there is life changing so I I
do think
it impacts mmm yes always good I've done
quite a few podcast recently um sort of
it's come up a few times on me and
business development front like if you
do get rejected five times off the
bounce I remembering that no one's died
and just perpetrated that it does help
lately yeah that's helped and so though
we've spoken a lot about and resilience
I think the second part of this is if we
do sort of work that and that resilience
muscle that that that gives us the best
possible chance of going the distance in
recruitment and as we all know not a lot
of people don't make it past the first
12 months in recruitment and so I guess
from from your own personal journeys and
experiences and the people that you've
met during your career what are some of
the sort of habits that you've seen most
commonly in recruiters that have gone
the distance what what comes up for you
guys when I ask you that someone go
first please I'll go I'll go okay and I
think I think a lot why I'd say the
first thing that comes to my mind that
without even thinking why is repetition
so and I linked it to resilience because
things will happen in your day your week
of being recruited where you may have to
be resilient that come out of and come
out of nowhere but I think a lot of
things happen to a lot of people because
they don't have that process they don't
have that repetition they don't have
their plan laid out to be able to spot
where things can go wrong and they don't
have their aides IVs the season at ease
and then all of a sudden they're jumping
into they're jumping into the unknown
and then that's when they get hit with
that with that kind of need for
resilience so for me is that ability to
repeat your processes repeating that you
need to do and then and then it's and
then it's all about analyzing what
you've done so a lot of people something
will go really wrong for them and they
won't and they'll they'll just take on
the chin they may be really really
resilient and you won't know that
they're in a bad place but they won't
look bastards too
why something went wrong they weren't
analyzed that they won't look at what
caused those setbacks and then it's it's
not going to happen moving forward so
yeah I'm a big stickler for process
repetition and they feel if you can
install that kind of framework as a
recruiter it helps helps manage the
unexpected hmm interest in and if
anything else to add there on the common
things that habits and things that we
see in people that go the distance have
it have a long tenure in recruitment
yeah I don't believe there is any common
habits other than the topic that we're
talking about so I think the process
point is a good one but I never kind of
like to process the moment I thought I
was in the only kind of process I jumped
out as quick as possible
my numbers were always all right so we
did a study once a large recruiter and
what we're trying to do is to unpick
that magic formula and this is why our
world so interesting right so we we
picked out the top ten billers out of a
thousand consultants and we were going
right we're gonna look at this crew and
work out what is the magic formula for
recruitment it's a successor yeah but
all these people were between 600
million pounds a year billers we had
five women five men so clearly gender
was irrelevant for different ethnic
backgrounds so that was irrelevant to we
had everything from at one end
incredibly processed driven people when
we did kind of the Thomas international
stuff on them at the time and at the
other end complete wide boy phone
jockeys who were wheeling and dealing IQ
was very variable even EQ was variable
actually which was a surprise in presume
that a high EQ but actually not having
EQ and not caring maybe help to manage
that emotional side you're talking about
the only one thing out and the ages were
22 to 55 said there was there was no
real sharing it was mental yeah you
couldn't of got a more mixed group of
people have you tried either personality
age background and we had everything
from the sons of millionaires to people
who grow up in a council state it was it
was ridiculous and the only one thing
was that they all scored above average
on the grit test which is yeah which is
exactly this it's a so that was the only
common denominator in all the top 0.1%
of one of the large recruiters in terms
of the big pillars that's really
interested in okay thanks for sharing
that a great insight and great question
just come through from Ashley Lawrence I
think really timely in the in the
current landscape so the question is and
I think back to your point early on
people have already made their bed and
these sorts of things like so Ashley's
question is what advice would you give
to recruiters to overcome current market
conditions and what metrics can you use
as a barometer of success or performance
and also see the current market
conditions I think that's a really
interesting question
so I guess only what are you what are
you making sure that what they're sort
of non-negotiable is for you in the last
couple of days that you're making sure
that obviously Ashley's your boss as
well so hopefully you answer this Quraan
ago she was view on currently right now
what you making sure you do on a daily
basis to make sure that you're doing the
right tivities so I think I think we all
think we're gonna I think we all think
we have the best quality service out
there are we all we all want to be
offering the best quality service I
think increasing that quality right now
is it's so so important and making it
apparent so is thinking outside the box
in terms of the offering that you have
for your clients being agile in terms of
in terms of offering them a strategy of
how you're going to approach the market
differently without without kind of
going into too much detail on it
doubling down on your car relationships
now is the most important thing and you
really will find the clients that do
trust you right now and find those
clients double down on those clients and
make sure that you you really offer the
quality service they want and it's a
two-way thing right a lot of it now is
it's not also telling our clients and
that's what they need to be doing and
ever
even more importantly now understanding
what their needs are that you might
presume their needs are they need a
cheaper service or they need temporary
people or you might presume all of these
things I just cause of what you're
hearing it might not necessarily be what
they're after they may be after
something completely different so really
identifying the need of your clients in
this current market conditions or
whatever and does a Down phrase have a
learner what was what so the last couple
of days a week what's the typical day
that like for you then and it's been
getting every single client that we are
engaged with on the phone and
identifying what their needs are right
now and what the landscape looks like in
the next couple of weeks because they're
not they're not going to give you the
answer right now they might not have the
answer right now but is identifying
their pain points right now their needs
what they need from us over the next
couple of weeks and once you know that
right so once you've taken that kind of
like audit of your client base and it's
it's then the next step yeah that's
that's why it's been like this week and
it's really refreshing right because
you're now speaking to clients and you
should be doing this all the time but
you're now speaking the clients and
really just you only have one purpose on
that call and what what is you what do
you need right now what do you need on
me and it's quite refreshing actually
and how that actually how's that being
received then yeah yeah really well
really well it's it's funny because you
have some client and now that one more
that one more contact from you because
they're the self isolate in other
socialists I just when I forget you got
your clients email me asking for a
virtual coffee because they're only but
yeah it's been it's been received really
well with with the clients that you
already kind of had that relationship
with in terms of the clients and maybe
country its with with with the best
quality service go into them now and and
and doing that is
but it's been very much focusing on
having good quality conversations with
with existing relationships that that's
you being focusing on yeah absolutely
but then on the flip side of that just
just include on flip side of that and
they were all gonna be clients out there
that aren't getting serviced efficiently
or effectively by by their recruiters
because I know agencies that have let 50
percent of their worst Africa overnight
like we're talking about yeah not having
the right values or morals are not being
prepared and so there's going to be
clients out there that need a bit of
lovin it's not the best way to put it
yes actually if they had the
relationship with those people have been
that guy as well yeah
one benefit ad that were using yeah well
I'd be tempted to you know really strip
it back and simplify it and you know not
a metric as such I think the most
important one which definitely ties into
what Oliver was saying which is actually
doing what you say you're going to do or
you know we laugh we joke all too often
we will have those calls because people
are give it a small time it's it's
getting on the phones you know the phone
calls are we just talking to people or
are we getting outcomes for from them
but if you are asked to do something
whether it's to follow up whether it's
to do something else just doing what you
say you're going to do ghost a huge way
in this job huge well I think that's
great and and then just on this point I
think this ties quite nicely with
Campbell's question and I think a big
part is to why I started this podcast
talking about can we change the
perception of the recruitment industry
and I think back to your point Andrew
and it's been great to see the amount of
people that are paying it forward and
being willing to help and canvas
question is do you think that the
resilience hardwork and empathy required
to be a recruiter at this current time
what we're talking about now Olly with
you speaking to clients like listening
to them listen to their needs
you said will this be recognised by both
candidates and clients and in turn have
hopefully have a positive impact on the
long term opinion of the recruitment
industry
yes you'd like oh and you're gonna like
this I I think now is the time to be
delivering as much content as much
marketing building an audience being
seen to be proactive sharing like the
key metrics for me I loved what the guy
said around you know it's a contact
sport that we're in right but I would be
Zune calling all morning and their
content marketing and social selling all
afternoon I think as an industry we have
a chance right now our audiences you
know on their laptops at home yeah we
have a chance right now to be zooming
them in the morning and then resetting
how they view their in our industry and
what we're doing in the afternoon via
all the good stuff that's going on
online so I'm hoping the current cadence
of social media traffic that our
industry is putting out is going to
continue onwards for some time to come
because it's it's a huge opportunity for
the industry right now unlike yeah I do
I do wonder how many home office sells
we're gonna see in the next 2-3 weeks I
don't know if that's gonna die down I
mean how many sheds yeah how many sheds
there's been a lot of them but no I
think yeah I've had a lot of
conversations over the last couple of
days on Hisham not sure how like should
I be talking about this at this current
time and all that and I think my sort of
view on has just been just like right
now is definitely the right song to be
front and center in your market being
something that's given value being
positive sharing ideas talking about the
solutions that you're coming up with
your clients talk sharing the challenges
and yeah I couldn't agree more it's
definitely worthwhile being front and
center in your market right now and I
think there's love seen loads of cool
stuff whoever's watching this there's
recruiters doing live webinars and give
him free interview video interview
advice or how to write your CV or
there's loads of things you could do
right now I think I've seen quite a few
videos on people doing they've created a
virtual pub and you can assume cool and
like there's so many cool things that
you could do right now which is going to
be all about bringing people together
and I think yeah I'd love to see like
this hard time now
having impacts on the real criminals in
the positive way and okay so um I'd love
to hear from you guys on this question
what what's the sort of one piece of
advice you've been given in the past
from a manager or colleague that you
think has had the biggest impact on how
you handle the tougher times in
recruitment tomorrow's another day
yeah nice and simple that that
definitely helped any for now so Lee
what's the what's the best advice that
you've been given yeah my opening
statement about the the net margin
between hope and certainty was was
something that's all I've always
remembered it was from a trainer that
and some an external training we had
come on you got a name inmate that no
good kudos we need to shared that mate
who is it
no I well there I didn't know if I was
allowed my fellows at the BBC know his
name his name's name's Jeremy now I
don't yeah he's great he's got a great
social presence as well so he's but no
he was the one he was one that said it
to me and and that's how I look that's
how I look at resilience now I really
analyze I'm really analytical with
everything I do and I really analyze and
if I feel like I was being hopeful in
that situation rather than I was being
certain in that situation whatever that
situation may be then then you kind of
hold yourself accountable to it and then
it helps you preempt preempt what's
going to happen and so yeah that close
that close that net margin between hope
and certainty and that's the best advice
I know Andrea best piece of advice yeah
my first ever manager in recruitment
told me never to be vulnerable to one
deal all I was so I allow me in the
beginning huh get all your hopes and the
holidays on one thing landing you got a
copy you got a yeah never be relentless
in ensuring that you're not just bomber
able to one deal making or break your
core so that's not the
and as you move up into xx search and
stuff where the numbers get bigger it
becomes even more important because you
can have a 40k swing on a deal
and so ya never be vulnerable so always
that means always have a backup
candidate firstly out and it means
always have a number of things going on
which sounds obvious but so many people
kind of get a couple of people that
final interview on something and then
yeah I've done that and we've all done
it and you kick now you kick back
but don't be horrible to candidate don't
be vulnerable to a deal and you're being
good shape yeah I like that
you really do you know tongue in cheek
zone about tomorrow's another day but
you do have to take a step back that
gives you perspective whether it's
another day or whether it is a lunchtime
or whether it is you know a bit of
terrible news the candidate not getting
it whatever it is you know take that
deep breath and get some clarity around
your thinking so that you can as I you
know my little theme and my strap choose
your response yeah love it yeah awesome
I was definitely victim of that last
week just really really focusing on what
I can't control and you can really you
can really I'll just think about this
event I'm not going to do it I was on
the phone so Olli get hopping over to
the UK on or you trapped in Dublin I
just thinking about all the time as soon
as I woke up looking at the news great
way to start my day
definitely not and like you can just but
you can really quickly find yourself in
that loop yeah daughter
that's woken up to be told you're not
doing your GCSEs you think most kids
would be absolutely delighted she's
crushed
you know she's a grafter she works
really really hard and you know her
immediate response is oh my god this is
terrible what's going to happen and you
know even though she hates it when I'm
coach mum it's you know what we don't
know enough at the moment you know there
is no point worrying about it
overthinking it because you're stealing
time from yourself yes yeah nothing just
really understanding that yeah it's that
yeah choose your response focus on what
you can control it just it just really
helps in situations like this light
really does
hey chef do you have a journal yeah so
I've been a bit lazy over the last
couple of months to be honest but I've
dropped off but I'm going to pick it
back up in the current environment I
think yeah yeah I think accountability
there Andrew we're all I've made my
public pledge but that was some good
advice someone gave me although I don't
know why I dropped it again it's made
yes in some of my own business and stuff
I've one of my biggest challenges has
been just fitting in all the typical
hisham stuff that makes me feel good
about it for now a lot of my eggs had
gone into the business basket for me and
but ya know journal in I'd say over the
last two three years I've journaled and
it's made a huge difference one of the
great the great things that I used to do
which is absolutely love is at the end
of the year I just book it there my
diary world read my whole journal for
the year and it's just such a great
exercise to do it like you is so easy to
forget where he was at the bigger than
the year let alone two months ago and
how you're feeling and what you're
talking about but yeah journaling for me
just write in how you feel down just
there's something really powerful in
that back to resilience because you've
just absolutely coined it going you know
I said about the elastic band yeah yeah
when you go back and you acknowledge how
far you've come so how do you stretch
the band you know that going into the
next year like look a brexit as an
example right look at where we were at
with that we've got on we've moved
forward we've got this when we look back
we'll know that the next piece of
uncertainty the next challenge
we'll be able to overcome it because
we've pushed our resilience a little bit
it's so easy to forget yeah I don't know
why it's just so easy to forget where
you was and the things that you overcame
and the challenges I don't know it's
interested in that and so yeah really
interesting question from Rob that's
sitting at the top there and again a bit
more in line with the current crime lab
I think it's a great one so Rob's
question and on the anger on the going
distant going the distance point how
important is it that
business owners managers team leads
really continue to qualify their own
staff and understand what is important
to them and what distance means to them
to help foster resilience I think that's
really interesting I said about the
values of the individuals the core
drivers if you don't know your team and
if they really don't know you right
you're not going to be on the same page
there is not going to be that
transparency which will build trust
which will create trust and which will
therefore build resilience I think it's
it's a basic fundamental thing that
needs to happen how often should people
to be doing that like how often should
people be checking in with their guys
and really trying to understand yeah
what their long-term vision is why they
didn't want to Dan I think if you're
talking real core values drivers and
motivators it's an exercise worth doing
every six months you know if you're
doing it properly it's not a 10-minute
conversation because we all know this
things happen in life and we
reprioritized
nobody has the same values throughout
their life yet we react we respond we
adapt okay and I just want to say to
everyone watching definitely still got a
couple of questions on the QA definitely
encourage you so got sort of 15 30
minutes left if you want to ask ask
Holly and rerun that any question then
make sure you pull it in there and we'll
ask it and something that I wanted to
ask you I think we've spoken a lot about
the challenging times overcoming the
difficult times and these sorts of
things but I think what's really
interesting is and the question on our
show guys is keeping yourself motivated
when you actually hit your Billings
target when you are at it actually at
the top of your game I think that's a I
think that's also a real challenge for a
lot of people that I've set them a lot
of people on the podcast recently where
they had that top biller badge
and when they call it they found it
really difficult because they all they
were finger my was maintaining that and
thinking about dropping that and if they
didn't have the top Billy Bad's what
were they so the question I have for you
guys is we're talking about the
challenging and these sorts of things
but how how can people keep their selves
motivated when after they've hit their
target and after they've hit their
Billings target or wherever that target
maybe yeah I think their error is and
I've worked with a few top villas on
this I think the error is just comparing
yourself internally mmm so I'd economy
I'd kind of go up to a half a million
biller whoo yeah
it may be let their ego get carried it
away a little bit and I've been showered
in massive bonuses gifts and a trip to
Miami every week and sit them down and
ask how they were doing against external
top villas for a start so other people
in their industry that might be
outperforming them some of their peers
who are same age who were in different
industries but outperforming them I
think it's and I don't know ever this is
healthy wonder after tell me but I think
what what always helped me was to have a
nemesis okay like a worthy adversary
right you know in in Australia I had one
he was awesome he was so bloody good and
whenever I felt like I was dining off I
was like what's he up to
I bet eating healthy competition it got
a bit unhealthy when I started scattered
pictures been scattered pictures of
invoices that are sending to his clients
over to him and stuff but generally it
was healthy despite my maturity because
it was always that kind of nagging thing
in the back of my head you know I come
in one morning and I wasn't quite on it
was like I bet Easter I bet he's killing
it yeah right I need to go so I think
there's something about habit and if you
look back in history top performers in
any sport or in any kind of thing that
it's always the worthy opponent and a
some kind of worthy adversary in there
hopefully in a healthy way yeah that's
interesting I like that right Rhonda
what do you think about that like how
can people remain motivated when they
feel like they've yeah they've hit their
targets or got to sort of maybe at the
peak I think what a lot of people aren't
very good at is doing that inner
analysis that self-reflection that
understanding of what personal
development looks like to them and you
can call it being the best version of
yourself if you want to
you know it sounds a bit cliche but you
know when we don't understand what our
existing version is and then what the
upgrade version looks like yeah we've
got nothing to aspire to so if you
really want to tap into the you know I
like to talk about brain chemistry and
happy chemicals and in this instance
we're talking about dopamine we're
talking about being able to motivate
ourselves and anticipate what that next
level looks like if you've got no idea
for example what your career looks like
after top Miller you know if you don't
have a focus on well actually I don't
just want to be top biller
for 2019 I want to be top Villa for 2020
2021 all know that well I've got to
achieve this and I'm gonna get this
promotion and that promotion is gonna
mean that you know it's life-changing
I'm gonna get a big a mortgage or we're
going to be able to do this you just you
have no direction really tapping into
you know you don't necessarily need a
coach to do that you can do it you know
by yourself there's some fantastic
resources out there but you know look at
what your what your map looks like
look Journal in last year where were you
where are you this year where do you
want to be the year after it doesn't
have to be a really prescriptive
five-year plan but if you can understand
you know what that journey looks like
it's much easier to then what you're
achieving it yeah I think yeah knowing
what the next part is yeah that's that's
probably the key your only real where
competition is you yesterday yeah yeah
that's it stop stalking these people
Andrew great slight slight change and
but I think definitely worth talking
about so and Joshua King I mean yeah
this must be really difficult for people
early on in their recruitment career in
the in the current landscape but Josh's
question if you were three months into
recruitment as I am what would be your
approach knowing what you know now to
this situation and I mean yeah Josh not
not the best cause to be dealt but yeah
I disagree
I disagree honestly I think that Josh
you don't realize it yet but this is the
best thing that's ever happened to you I
can't tell you the amount of people who
joined recruitment in 2008 2009 who have
gone on to be successful business owners
and I think it's because if you're born
into the fire then as and you won't have
to work at a certain pace a certain
creativity a certain hustle to get by
then as the market starts to come up you
are gonna fly mate so hang in there you
haven't been dealt a bad hand I think
you've been dealt potentially the best
possible hand for your career adversity
we're talking about you can get through
this Josh you're gonna breeze it yeah I
think youngster this question about what
you could be doing and I think there is
that whether it's this situation which
is difficult for all of us there's some
first-time experiences for everybody but
I'm a firm believer of modeling
excellence and looking at the people
around you that are seeing success are
working with particular clients that
have still got the lines of comms up
that still want to be billing and so on
you know have conversations be bold and
I've always said you know no questions a
bad question I think just be inquisitive
and speak to the people that are around
you that have been in the game a little
bit longer and look at what they're
doing and their responses right now yeah
I mean yeah Josh should definitely be
looking at the people around you and
asking for advice and help and I love
that I love that you just disagree to me
that Andrew I think that's I love that
you just come back and nothing that's
that's great and aliena fence ads and
that what do you think like if you were
really an early on in your recruitment
career knowing what you know now in the
sort of current landscape and market
what what sort of things would you be
thinking about or advice you'd be given
yourself yeah going back to going and
going back to what we're talking about
about the external environment as well
someone gave me a really great analogy
on that and when we talk about being
that top biller and like what's next
andrew saying you always look internally
so true and include us to you him to be
honest because we now have the ability
in in many ways including the podcast to
actually look externally as what's going
on before you had no idea you had no
information so so I'm giving that
analogy about having a jar of fleas with
a lid on and the fleas would jump and
just hit the lid obviously if you take
the lid
fleas would still only jump that high
and only reach that high until you put
another flea and it jumped a bit further
yeah and all the feed see that going
what's going on here like I didn't know
you could do that and I'm gonna kick
Kevin gave me that and he asked a
question early so I'm gonna give him
that one but I wanted to say I wanted to
give that analogy out so we're talking
about it but in terms of is it Josh
Martha's answered it's gone it's gone
in terms of what I do now I genuinely
think it's a time and again he probably
doesn't know this yet so he has to be
around the right people but it's a real
time where the opportunity to be
different and the opportunity to raise
the bar to a level that is that is other
people aren't doing the industry this is
the time to do it you can get you can so
easily we've all done it get caught up
and the noise and the business of the
industry and you see so much going on
you see all these successful people in I
feel like it's all about being
fast-paced all the time and I think now
is potentially a time where you can
really differentiate your your offering
in terms of the quality of what you're
doing and raise the bar if that if
that's through social selling if that's
through day-to-day phone-based of
whatever it is I think it is a time now
where you can potentially I'm going to
trim the fat a little bit but as an
individual you can really raise the bar
and what you're doing on a day to day
basis mm-hmm and just to finalize that
point then cuz I think this is great
question Claire just said so what what
help do you think is good for people to
ask for right now in the current climate
I think that's a good question that what
should people be asking palatable I'm
gonna say mindset not just because
that's what I do but I think mine said
it you know we don't typically offer
that across the industry yeah if we get
people's heads in the right places and
the way in which we respond to it
definitely changes yeah so yeah but I
think that's the thing as you said the
historically that hasn't always been the
conversation so like how do you even
approach awesome help on that
like I guess not I mean do you know I
did is the question gone did you move
there and yeah I think I think there's
still despite yeah the the industry we
still struggle
we're far more open about it I think
that there are people that are going to
be surrounding us as individuals that do
respond in the right way that can give
you advice that you know I think there's
a really big difference between like
positive chirpy thinking and what I
would call doing let's stick in the
plaster over it oh it's going to be fine
oh it's going to be fine and I think
it's that real conversation real honesty
and and and really not being afraid to
have that level of conversation with
somebody you know I think that is it it
is it that obvious to say that
transparency communication I think
that's at the minimum what we give in
teams at the moment mmm so I guess with
that a good question from James just on
this point is like how important is
downtime and switching off when it comes
to going the distance and McCrimmon do
you think again maybe there's something
that has become more in this sort of
conversation over the last couple years
well being and a lot of businesses that
I've been working with speaking to now
have personal development budgets that
have well-being plans and all these
types of things but so what what can
recruitment employees do to ensure their
people maintain a balance I think that's
really interest in I think we've gone I
think I think we've done well to get to
ten past seven and not talk about this
but it's good it's probably it's
probably quite an important part isn't
it in terms of like extracurricular in
terms of mental health physical health
it's actually probably is has a real
strong correlation to resilience in
recruitment now the one thing the one
thing recently for me in terms of
extracurricular things outside of work
that have really helped it is actually
an education thing I think we can get so
when recruitment in such our own little
bubble and we speak to recruiters all
the time it's all or you go home and
talk about recruitment all you ever talk
about it's such a bubble and I think
external education has been a real real
good thing for me in terms of books
podcasts whatever that may be
yeah it's only new for me doing I mean
like last year I had a new year's
resolution to read one book every month
and I read one book all year so
I'll get I'll get about it but this year
I've had a big thing about it in terms
of being able to turn recruitment off
and do so and do something how do you
think that helped you it gave me so many
more ideas it gave me so many more ideas
because there's so many things in the
big wild world it's so relevant to
recruitment that you never even think of
until you go and find it doesn't mean
you're kind of always talking about like
getting a candidate to interview always
talking about closing a deal it's all
really specific to recruitment sometimes
and there's so many things you could
learn in terms of that personality trait
or or sales skills or just fictional
stuff whatever it may be that actually
you then relate to your day job as a
recruiter and you kind of implement it
in management or in actual recruitment I
found it so fascinating and like I said
I need to do more exercise and I mean we
all need to do more exercise I think
that'll help in terms of Education I
like an extracurricular activity that's
really helped it's really how my day job
of thumbing do you think that's helped
do you think that's helped you solve
like continue with your criminal career
because obviously you've been in the
industry for quiet quite a while now do
you think that's had an impact on you
sort of them going the distance yeah
definitely it's definitely reframed my
like mindset of of like the recruitment
career if that makes sense like given me
I've never given me a vision about
different paths it could take just by
looking outside and looking inward so
yeah absolutely I think it I think it's
good to get out of this bubble a little
bit and look inwards definitely okay and
then Andrew what what do you like what
do you think employers can do to ensure
they're sort of trying to influence or
impact their the work-life balance that
a lot of people need in one today
anything that you're saying we've had
yeah I I think we're moving to is more
tailored employment experiences hmm so I
don't work life balance is what we kind
of talk about work-life integration and
because I think it means different
things for different people and I think
what we're gonna get is rather than just
exchanging our time for money and it'll
be interesting to see how this goes with
the current climate as well I think what
we're getting is someone agreeing to
deliver an outcome and some value but
then there being then being able to
tailor to an extent with some freedom
within a framework how they go around
doing that accessing all the resources
that the company provides so I think
it's going to be a more tailored I think
it's I think where people go wrong with
work-life balances they go well they
blanket it for everybody yeah it's
totally didn't like work-life balance to
me is totally different than work-life
balance it's so true to my wife you know
yeah because we have different
preferences and ways of working and we
peek at different times during the day
and all that stuff so so yeah I think I
think it needs to be tailored yeah I
think that and then again that ties into
over communicating to the people in your
business and these types of things that
can be part of it Connor yeah so just on
your point and only it be interested
actually Claire just said like what what
podcasts of obviously besides the
recruitment rollercoaster what what what
what podcast have you really enjoy what
podcasts are always in your podcast
library that you've always always want
to listen to and have had a quite good
impact yeah there's that there's a
really good I follow a guy called Jordan
Jordan Peterson who's like a player
University and that's the one that I I
bought his book and quite hard read that
one yeah 12 way no the second one wasn't
my father was alive yeah I've really
liked it but I was just so bad at
reading you know yeah and I was like can
I listen to him and then I've started
listening to all the podcasts of him of
his and it's been it's just so
left-field from recruitment but it's so
engaging and it's so like almost
inspiration I we talk about we talk
about what we're looking for externally
and sometimes you are looking for a bit
of inspiration aren't you are looking
for someone to look up to and a goal to
reach and yeah I found that with with
his with his stuff there was some things
that were more closely aligned to
recruitment
there's a marketing podcast listen to
our comm remember the name I feel really
bad I should be booking it yeah and
there was actually a HR podcast a really
interesting to like understand what
people within the world of HR talking
about and trying to get into the get
into their frame of mind so there's a
few things yeah absolutely things that
nothing to do recruitment you know
cricket pay lenders of the world
podcasters probably some two of those I
think many many people are here want to
listen to it but but yeah even if it's
even if it's not pure educational
sometimes a bit of fiction a bit of non
professional is helps me a lot as well
just just enough Andrew what was what's
always in your podcast library yeah so
humans 2.0 is awesome humans to point
humans 2.0 okay yeah yeah that's like a
personal development on I like I like
impact theory in that the area impact
hit from Tom days yeah I like I like him
in that genre obviously some of the Joe
Rogan's stuff he's good all his bloody
long so yeah he has he has I think he
has some some really really interesting
people in there as well yeah okay cool
so as we shall come to the end of this I
guess what what would be your sort of
sort of what what just to leave people
with things to go away with or like
would be your sort of pipe messages to
sort of where we are today with what's
going on like what what what should be
other know Ward your message be to
people today that no doubt are going to
need resilience gonna have to push on if
they're serious about going the distance
in the crime at what what's your sort of
parting message for the people that and
have very corny give them as their time
mime would simply be it's very very
tempting right now to second-guess all
the things that are happening you know
there's rumors there's scare mongering
there's a huge amount of fear that's
just everywhere you know god this the
school chats the wasthat groups it's
just frightening and know if we allow
ourselves to sort of be affected by this
if we jump on that in terms of our
thought process it's just not going to
take us in a good space and mine would
simply be you know really think about
what you know to be fat what you can
control and then choose your response
you know it's dead time at the moment
you can plan to a certain degree I think
having the plan definitely helps with
the resilience piece but very very
simply it's just don't be impacted and
affected by the rumors that you hear you
know sanity check it a little bit it's
definitely hard to do that times Andrew
what are you thinking about I'm thinking
about people need to avoid a scarcity
short-term mindset hmm which is fear
driven building on what Rhonda was
eloquently talking about there but I
think we need to avoid scarcity based
mindsets in the same way that businesses
need to make sure that you know history
will judge the well individuals need to
as well and I think you need to conduct
yourself in a way that you're happy with
I think need to be super proactive focus
on the controllables and just try and
fight against the short-term thinking
I'm a big believer in reciprocity and I
think the more you can serve people in
this time of need and pay into the
ecosystem the better off you'll be and I
think it's a unique opportunity to
reframe the industry and build
relationships that'll serve you for the
next decade if you get it right so look
to pay in rather than extract and the
other thing the other bit of advice I
would give recruitment consultants
internally
is to have empathy for their leaders
yeah it's so easy to criticize until
you've set and it's a little bit like
parenting like we all will we all moan
about our mum and dad and then we turn
into the months we have kids right
that's a story yeah it's magic
that leadership's like that so like my
big thing would say would be to say back
your boss I could promise you they've
got a lot on their shoulders yeah I love
that go and ask them how you can help
yeah I think that's nothing that's great
do that love only only what would be
your sort of parting force words the
Android AI talked about the
controllables and I think the blurred
lines between the control and the
controllables and the uncontrollable is
now more defined so so it gives you the
chance to really understand what you can
control and he gives you the chance to
really focus on him before Paula Deen's
the internet was a bit slow then they
unfortunately nothing down sorry Olli I
think you know where did you get start
again mate you need start from the basic
mate yeah no there's a billion so I go
now you need to start out from the top
mate I was just saying the the
definition and the blurred lines between
what you can control and what you can't
control now it's probably more than fine
than ever which means on the positive
side that you know what you can control
now and really gives you the focus on
being able to control it that's my one
my one thought my other thought is was
it is always it's always been no no yeah
no sorry sorry I've been mean to buy and
then it just lagged a little bit Oh
an amazing book for what all he's
talking about is Viktor Frankl man
search for meaning
it is unbelievable about resilient
design control
unbelievable great book highly
recommended write well and look well
that was the the first live audio only
you gave it a good I'll go mate there we
got it thank you
[Laughter]
yeah only someone just said they look
like it looks like you've been to that
virtual pub in some of those scenes
there when it was just yeah the internet
wasn't very good and below I just wanted
to say thank you ollie
Rhonda Andrew I thought you're great and
some great answers
thank you everyone the this obviously
you've given on your time this evening
and really really appreciate it it means
a lot and Hannah just put a quick
message on plan on doing any more
webinars definitely plan on doing more
webinars and if you have enjoyed it
please do let me know feedbacks really
welcome and feel free to to share all
over the socials let everyone know that
you tuned in to the the podcast webinar
help you get in front of more people but
and look thank you everyone and thank
you to the panelists
she's guys cheers thank you thanks
fishin